at this point i think a significant
proportion of americans get their
information from comedy shows
it's like comedians that become like the
next generation truth-tellers
you have these politicians that now at
this point people don't trust very much
and then you have like the filter of the
news media
which unfortunately now also many
americans don't trust that much and you
have that like the sense of polarization
uh and then comedians are saying things
that make us laugh
but often there's like massive massive
amounts of truth in the jokes that
they're they're telling
um i think it's one reason why uh people
are gravitating towards people like dave
chappelle
as almost like the the uh the people who
can tell us what's going on
i i think so which is
in a lot of ways unfortunate because
it's not really the purpose
of of comedy i mean comedy should be a
part of it
it's part of the information ecosystem
but when it becomes your primary source
of information that's scary as well
and the fact that we don't have enough
trusted sources of information
is what is hurting our democracy and i
think we feel it even in
places that we do trust that they hold
back you know when you watch all the
sunday morning programs and
they interview you know the chief of
staff for
for the president they they go
soft on everybody because they do want
access they do want them to come back
and you feel like wow these interviews
should all be way tougher
i mean we are in crisis mode and how
many times i watch it someone
in politics get interviewed and i think
wow that was a pretty easy interview for
that person at a moment when tens of
thousands of people are dying based on
these
decisions and i think people like comedy
because the comedians
don't you know they don't have the
access to interview everybody
everyone but they don't have to put on
that filter of being full of
they don't have to be sweet about it
they could just say
this is madness this is hypocrisy this
is corruption
in the way you know a lot of journalists
want to uh but i don't think they can
say it in the same
term yeah journalists can't just throw
down that way because it somehow makes
them seem reactive
or biased which to me i mean at this
point like you said if you don't have a
strong point of view you're not
uh being awake or truthful and i've been
on those news programs as a subject
and i can say very much that if you were
let's say
a government official and you were put
on the spot in these interviews one to
your point
they'll probably go somewhat easy on you
if you're in a position of influence
um and sometimes that like the questions
get
hashed out and vetted and pre-approved
before you agreed to show up so there's
that yes
you could be like hey look don't ask me
about x and y and the audience doesn't
know that by the way
doesn't know but but that's a giant
thing for the audience not to know
that you know going on these sunday
shows or in certain interviews
is the same as you know me going on the
tonight show that there's a
pre-interview
and that they're not going to come on if
you're going to ask about russian
bounties
or or something else and that that's the
only way they will come on
so it's filtered in ways that are not
transparent
to people because i you know it's
it's like the world has turned and
the news can't seem to adjust to it so
for instance
there's clearly a moment where you know
when donald trump said we have 15 cases
and it's going to go down to zero
we we know for sure that someone
privately said to
the president it's not going to zero
it's going to be hundreds of thousands
soon
and he made a political calculation not
to tell the country
and to not be honest about what we were
in for
and he set the conditions for what led
to tens of thousands of additional
people
dying who wouldn't have if at that
moment
he prepared and prepared the country
now can a journalist say that directly
which is you chose your political career
over the lives of thousands of people
and you are responsible for that
because in this meeting you were told
how this was probably going to progress
and you won't see people be that tough
on them you i've never
heard anyone say to the people around
the president
when was he told this was going to get
out of control
what day did someone say it's not going
to be 15
it's going to be millions or tens of
thousands
and what did he say what did he say
and why did his messaging not change for
weeks and weeks and weeks or
months and that is the the question for
this election
when was the president told what was
going to happen and why did he reject
that and why did he not tell the country
well the second thing i'd say about
these interviews judd is that
if you are let's say a government
official
number one there's the certain types of
questions you might get asked but number
two if your goal is to
get out of that interview um saying
nothing like you can do it
you just don't answer the question i do
it in movie interviews people ask
something and if i don't have an answer
for it i just say anything
i mean that's the funny thing about
interviews you know people could say
uh you know what's it like uh you know
working with with this actor
so you know what here's the great thing
about working in new york
you know what i mean like
totally we're now wondering which actor
you do not want to talk about what it's
really like to work with them
but but yes it's exactly like that john
where what happens with if you were an
official and you didn't have to do this
when you were
talking about your movies but if you're
an official
let's say you have a six minute
interview segment what they do is they
sit the official down and they say here
are six minutes of talking points
and if they ask a question that uh is
not comfortable for you just go to
this you will then fill up the interview
time and it's over
uh yeah like like that that's the way it
works uh where
um so it's comical by the way if you
watch it
and you see someone you know talking to
kellyanne conway
and they ask a direct question and then
she says you know what we should be
talking about
is why you guys keep talking about blah
blah blah and sometimes the journalists
will go i hear what you're saying but
can you please answer this question
she'll do it again she'll do it a third
time and then they're basically out of
time
yeah you can run at the clock on those
interviews all the time because it's
just like the cadence of the tv
um format really where
and i've been in the format you know now
obviously like hundreds of times
and uh most of the time when i was
running i was like i'm trying to get
this message out
um but sometimes they'd ask me about
something that i had no interest in
talking about
my propensity just to answer the
question you asked me a question i'll
probably try and answer it
but there were there were some times
when it was like
um you know some something like along
the lines of what you're saying it's
like you asked
asked about like an actor uh working
with him and you're like i'd rather not
talk about this oh they could go
someplace else
that's why representative katie porter
should be the person on all of these
shows interviewing everybody
because when you see you see her you
know speak to people
she was talking to the head of lockheed
the other day yeah she's tough
she's she's smart and um saying why are
you applying for
uh ppp or whatever for help
she's like you made 15 more this year
than the year before and he's like
everyone's asking for help
and she's like yeah that doesn't make it
right why are you asking for help
and you know he and he dances around it
uh but she just keeps doing it and i
think a lot of our
congress people have found a way to
prepare for those moments
in a much tougher way than we've ever
seen before
and we need to see more of that i mean
you know that chris wallace interview
the other day with donald trump was
fascinating because
he he went harder than we've seen most
people
go to say no that's not true what you're
saying
and donald trump is clearly shocked
that anybody's like no i have the
information
what you're saying is not correct and we
really need that from everybody
because obviously everyone should always
tell the truth
but these questions cost
tens of thousands of lives
and for some reason it's like
everything's been so normalized
and republicans they want to normalize
death they want to normalize this so
that we all go
well it was only 380 000 people
when really maybe it could have been
25 000 for the whole country they want
us to think it's
fine and it isn't fine and it is a
political calculation
to time out what happens with this
pandemic to get reelected as opposed to
just
do what helps thank you for listening in
i hope you enjoyed this conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode
[Music]
you